der titel meines vortrags ist leider
muss man im nachhinein sagen nur die
halbe miete also der erste teil ist ein
kritischer teil zum sogenannten sein
sollen probleme also eine kritik des
sein sollen problems und die folgerungen
dieser kritik ist dann diese
formulierung die ich dann für den
zweiten teil gewählt habe ich denke so
nach habe ich ja schon mal gestern
gesagt nach 40 50 jahren der diskussion
muss man auch sich mal fragen ob dieses
problem überhaupt ein problem ist oder
zumindest adäquat formuliert ist und das
will ich im ersten teil tun und da will
ich aber auch schon und das wird auch
ein bisschen historisch sein will ich
zwei sachliche thesen die dann im
zweiten teil eine rolle spielen auch
schon vorbereiten oder vertreten nämlich
erstens dass ein grundproblem der ganzen
sache das hat mir auch bei mehreren
vorträgen schon gesehen natürlich diese
nicht ganz klare formulierung ist ob es
nun jetzt beim sein um die wirklichkeit
als solches das denken der wirklichkeit
oder die die sprachliche äußerungen also
einigen vorträgen wir es gehört haben
wurde sehr schnell eben dann auf die
deskriptive aussage übergegangen auch
bei dir grad wieder und das scheint mir
jetzt schon nicht so ganz trivial zu
sein weil die schwierigkeit in
philosophischer hinsicht natürlich jetzt
nicht nur die verbindung von aussagen
ist sondern halt die rückführung auf
irgendeine faktizität und das zweite
problem ist und es deutet sich dann im
zweiten teil des titels an das wertungen
als zwischen glied zwischen
beschreibungen und vorschreibungen
regelmäßig mit nichtachtung gestraft
werde ich bei einer gesagt werden oder
mit nichtachtung behandelt werden und es
wird so getan weil manche autoren das
als ob die auch eine art von säulen
werden aber das möchte ich also relativ
klar und vehement bezweifeln und will
auch versuchen das zu zeigen also zuerst
zum ersten teil der kritik dass sein
sollen problemen
die frage ist wie kann man denn eine art
von kritik anbringen ich denke dass
grundsätzlich reflexion erfordernis der
philosophie verlangt
das problem die nur oder vorrangig durch
die philosophie angenommen werden
zunächst eine gründliche selbstkritik
vorgenommen wird und zwar mit zwei
fragen handelt sich um echtes problem
oder nur an durch die philosophie
erzeugt das beziehungsweise angenommen
ist ein problem gerade die die moderne
philosophie wittgenstein und so hat das
ja sehr prominent gemacht und dann etwas
wenn es kein problem ist ist die problem
formulieren adäquat und das scheint mir
nun jetzt gerade bei diesem sein sollen
so genannten sein soll das problem
besonders wichtig zu sein weil es ja ein
irgendeine deutschsprachige formulierung
ist also ich wüsste jetzt keine
englische publikation wo irgendein ding
ort problem oder ein problem oder
irgendwie sowas formuliert wird also ich
denke vor allem wenn wir es auf deutsch
sprachig so formulieren dann müssen
besonders kritisch darauf schauen und
gut schulman lies wurde schon erwähnt
ich ziemlich interessanter weise genau
auf diese göttinger bild schrift von
günter patrick der ist denke ich im
deutschsprachigen raum ist erst einmal
als problem also formuliert hat und da
ist natürlich ein unterschied zwischen
ob man zwei sein sollen kluft oder
seinen stollen tourismus spricht oder
ist von einem problem spricht und und
stuhlmann lies geht dann auch sehr
schnell über ohne erklärung zu dass er
sagt sein sollen problem ist das
verhältnis von tatsachen und normen und
dann sofort ohne weitere erklärung von
tatsachenfeststellungen und normen und
das ist natürlich schon eine
verschiebung die nicht ganz
unproblematisch was kann ein kriterium
für ein schein problem in der
philosophie sein was kann ein problem
kriterium für ein problem meine
philosophie sagen ich würde
vorschlagen dass es keine rein internen
kriterien für solche schein probleme
geben kann sonst könnte sich die
philosophie also mit münchhausen der
lügenbaron selbst aus dem sumpf ziehen
in denen sie selbst ihre probleme
erzeugt und dann auch rechtfertigt ein
kriterium das mir jetzt eingefallen ist
vielleicht gibt es andere das kann man
mal diskutieren wäre ob es halt auch in
anderen wissenschaftsbereich mode von
alltag auftaucht und ich kann jetzt
keine wissenschaft oder keinen alltags
zusammenhang mir schon mal dass sein
sollen das problem in dieser
formulierung begegnet wäre also ich auch
im nicht in der rechtswissenschaft also
ich kenne auch in der automatischen
rechtswissenschaft klar in der
rechtsphilosophie die sich mit dem
problem beschäftigt an aber kenne ich
jetzt keinen fall wo man irgendwie das
nun thematisiert hätte und das ist
natürlich doch irgendwie ein indiz dass
es zumindest dieser formulierung auch
ein selbst gemachtes problem ist und um
das jetzt etwas weiter aufzuklären will
ich einige historische splitter oder
wurzeln kurz nennen so dass wir uns mal
an diese formulierung etwas heran tasten
um sie etwas besser bewerten zu können
also die antike kannte bei den
klassikern platinum name ist das eine
enge verbindung von seinen und guten die
dann bei aristoteles durch die
zurückweisung der ideen lehre weiter
entwickelt wurde und in der schule stick
in dem axiom nz wohnung convert und uhr
auf eine formel gebracht wurde also
diese verbindung
die war so eine art ja kann man sagen
wahrheit die man allgemein angenommen
hat also genau das gegenteil von einer
trennung oder ein problem sondern der
annahme einer verbindung und die wurde
dann man kann sagen die ganz neuzeitlich
entwicklung ist so dass diese verbindung
gelockert wurde und im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert weitgehend gelöst wurde das
ist so die generelle entwicklung und ich
will jetzt ein bisschen auf diesen
neuzeitlichen entwicklungen schauen
ich habe auch wieder dass dieses
berühmte jungs zitat natürlich mir
vorgenommen und es steht jetzt auch noch
mal also wir können uns noch mal
anschauen
es wurden ja auch schon einige
interpretationen genannt und auch ein
fehler es keine vollständige machen aber
es scheint mir jetzt nicht wirklich eine
nur logische aussage zu sein wie jetzt
habe brandhorst gemeint hat sondern es
scheint mir so zu sein dass erstens ist
es nun eben bemerkungen bei jugend
zweitens geht es im juni mehrere autoren
von philosophischen systemen es geht
ihnen nicht um die moral als solche oder
die die alltags ethik drittens ist so
dass tatsächlich sagt dass nur der
übergang unverständlich ist und dass
gründen notwendig sind und er selber
gibt ja solche gründe mit seiner gefühls
ethik als ein paradigma für dieses
übergang und dem letzten satz kommt dann
tatsächlich spricht da von didaktischen
also ich interpretiere das so dass er
das sagt was ja auch viele heute sagen
eine logische ableitung ist nicht
möglich aber das ist mehr oder minder
wenn wir jetzt ihnen nicht vorliegen
wenn dir nicht folgen so ein bisschen
triviales und entscheidend ist halt die
frage wie sind gründe der verbindung
wir müssen die aussehen und die gibt da
glaube ich in seinem gesamten werk an
verschiedenen stellen also das ist eben
nur eine sehr partiell wahrheit wenn man
jung darf in anspruch nimmt das keine
streng logisch detektive formal logische
ableitung zwischen ihnen ist dort
möglich ist sondern der der kern dieser
aussage ist man muss die registrieren
dass die das verhältnis man muss es
behandeln und man muss gründe für
verbindungen geben das scheint mir die
aussage zu sein
bei kant findet sich dann eine radikale
verinnerlichung des guten mit der
bekannten formulierung am beginn der
grundlegung zur metaphysik der sitten
das allein der gute wille ohne
einschränkungen für gut gehalten werden
könnte und der beurteilung der pflichten
durch den kategorischen imperativ und
das moralische gesetz in mir dass
dadurch lockert kann natürlich die
verbindung zu diesem umfassenden guten
die noch in dieser alten formel
nz bonum convert und er bestand während
dann die lehre von der freiheit als
letzte grundlage des sittengesetz und
dann vor allem auch von fakten und der
vernunft hat es ja gestern schon sehr
schön ausgeführt die verbindung
aufrechterhalten kann kommt auch hatten
wir ja gesehen das wort sollen
das ist eine verengung auf den
verpflichtungskredit platziert während
wertungen weniger häufig kommt und dann
vor allem bei kant ja auch mit dieser
die chemie zwischen würde und wert in
der grundlegung eigentlich eskortiert
wird also sagt ja die werte sind eben
nicht das entscheidende sondern die
würde im hinblick auf und die stellung
des menschen als gesetzgeber im
gemeinsamen reicht der zweck was sich
bei kant nicht findet so weit ich das
jetzt sehr aber aber vielleicht kann
mich da jemand aufklären so eine
explizite entgegen setzung von sein und
sollen in dieser formulierung und oder
auch eine diskussion also ich weiß es
jetzt nicht sie ist jetzt nicht so ganz
und eine erklärung wäre halt das kann ja
sowieso den science begriff nicht so ins
zentrum stellt stärker den naturbegriff
und das für ihn vielleicht alle diese
phänomene auch die die praktische
verpflichtung des sit des moralischen
gesetz in mir eine form von sein werden
und dann wäre natürlich würde dieser
gegensatz in dieser formulierung nicht
bestehen
hegel verklammert dann sein und gutes in
seinem idealismus wieder stärker und
verbindet auch die beiden praktische
termine von säulen und guten wieder sehr
viel intensiver als kant dies getan hat
ich habe ein paar zitate hier auf das
handout geschrieben wenn sie sich das
anschauen
das gute bleibt so ein sollen es ist an
und für sich aber dass sein als die
letzte abstrakte unmittelbarkeit bleibt
gegen dasselbe auch als ein nicht sein
bestimmt die absolute idee als identität
der theoretischen der praktischen idee
die absolute idee allein ist sein und
das gute säulen ist bloß subjektivität
die in wirklichkeit aufgehoben wird die
substanz in welcher das absolute sollen
ebenso sehr sein ist also im grunde ist
für hegel dieses
säulen was er mit dem guten gleichsetzt
nur eine art von subjektivität vorstufe
für die aufhebung in dem absoluten sein
dieser dieser absoluten idee der
sittlichkeit bei lotze kommt dann
interessanterweise dieser wert begriff
sein und werten wird entgegen gesetzt
und dann auch mit dieser diesem modus
sein existiert während ideen und werte
dagegen nicht sind sondern nur gelten
also da haben wir nun diese gegensätze
nicht von sein und sollen sondern von
sein und werten und gleichzeitig diese
differente modus sein ist während die
werte halt gelten das ist tatsächlich
nur eine starke trennung von sein und
sollen
ich habe hier ein zitat von helmut kohl
der diese ganze entwicklung mal
zusammenfasst und dass ich nach wie vor
immer noch eine sehr gute analyse finde
zutat mit der zersetzung des
metaphysischen science begriffs verfällt
auch der begriff des guten und jeder
seiner bestandteile entwickelt die
tendenz das ganze gute darstellen zu
wollen
in dieser parzellierung verliert das
begriffs wort seinen rang
teils wird es als terminus eine sich als
selbstständige disziplin begreifen die
ethik eingeschlossen teils wird es sind
die freiheit der umgangssprache
entlassen und damit dem dichterischen
und praktischen gebrauch über antwortet
der statusverlust den das gute erleidet
führt schließlich dazu dass ein ersatz
wird seine stelle einzunehmen versucht
der aus der nationalökonomie importierte
wert ist das kaputt mord um des einst
lebendigen begriffs das gute losgerissen
vom sein und theologisch entwurzelt
nicht mehr über sein wie bei den
katholiken sondern eher unter seien nur
noch geltend klammer wie auch wir vom
dollar oder der mark sagen dass sie so
viel gelten das ist der zur kurzlebigen
philosophischen ehren aufgestiegene
wertbegriffe also das ist so ein
bisschen die die komische bewertung
dieses diese entwicklung zum wert
begriff hermann cohen findet man dann
kant interpretation die iks extremen
immer auf dieses sein und sollen ab
stellt also da wird kant in diese
dichotomie getrieben als bewertung steht
immer sein und sollen obwohl man eben da
sehr zweifelhaft sein kann und bei cohen
findet sich interessanterweise auch die
idee dass die gesamte ethik oder die
gesamte praktische sphäre eben als
rechtswissenschaft zu bestehen ist also
die rechtswissenschaft soll die
mathematik der geisteswissenschaften
sein und soll ebenso sein dass wir den
reinen willen in dieser ethischen
willens in der rücksicht auf recht und
staat konstruieren sagt hermann queen
und das führt natürlich zu einer
typisierung dieses praktischen durch das
sollen
und jetzt noch ein bisschen
ausführlicher zum rechtsphilosophischen
neu kaliß muss also ballast findet sich
zum beispiel dann der wert begriff ist
das als sachliche prius des norm
begriffs vereinzelte zitate des
gegensatz von sein und sollen und bei
radbruch haben wir dann eine klare
hingegen setzung sollen setzte komma
werturteile die werden auch
gleichgesetzt können nicht induktiv auf
science feststellung sondern nur
detektiv auf andere sätze gleiche art
gegründet werden wert betrachtung und
science betrachtung liegen als
selbständiger je in sich geschlossener
kreis nebeneinander da sind schon die
zwei sphären und vollständig getrennt
und das ist das wesen des methoden
dualismus säulen sätze sind nur durch
andere sollen setzte begründbaren
beweisbar
eben deshalb sind die letzten säulen
setzte und beweisbar axiom a tisch nicht
der erkenntnis sondern nur des
bekenntnisses fähig also dass diese
abgetrennte sphäre des säulen für sollen
set ist dann nur das bekenntnis fähig
einige wissenschaftliche entscheidung
ist nicht mehr möglich und daraus
resultiert dann der relativismus
radbruchs der halt die man diese zwei
reiche kennt die nicht verbunden werden
können man kann sagen dass es dann
natürlich die die
these der unmöglichkeit eine verbindung
zwar nicht nur einer logischen sondern
offenbar auch einer einer wertenden
begründen also bei radbruch ist diese
digitalisierung so stark dass es eben
nicht nur eine streng logischer
ableitung impliziert sondern auch eine
werten begründen
schließlich die das extrem dieser dieser
spaltung sein sollen bei kelsen sollen
ist der tat sollen ist der normative
sinn eines international auf das
verhalten anderer gerichte nacktes in
diesem sollen ist das dürfen können mit
einbegriffen also hier ist auch dürfen
können drin
die norm ist ein säulen der willensakt
dessen sinn sie ist ein sein
der unterschied zwischen sein und sollen
kann nicht mehr erklärt werden also so
eine summe sagen abbruchs dogmatik kann
ich hier definiert nie erklärt werden er
ist unserem bewusstsein unmittelbar
gegeben sollen ist der subjektive sinn
jedes willensakt eines menschen und das
sollen ist als objektives sollen eine
gelten der den adressaten binden enorm
und was nun ist nun die bedingungen
dieser objektives sollen wenn es eben
einen übergeordneten ermächtigung suckt
einen übergeordneten willensakt gibt und
dann wird natürlich sollen
ausschließlich eine positive menschliche
setzung wir haben zum stufen bau des
sollens der immer von einem
übergeordneten rein formalen
ermächtigung suckt des wollens abhängt
und am schluss braucht man eben dann so
eine art transzendentalen logische
voraussetzung eine ermöglichung
bedingung der grund morton norm also bei
gelsen findet man kann man sagen eine
extreme trennung der beiden bereiche
eine völlige verdrängung des wertes und
damit des umfassenden guten auch der
begründung der vernunft der rationalität
die zwischen diesen sphären vermittelt
und damit eine komplette verengung auf
das sollen bei gleichzeitiger
vollständiger positv hrung im sinne
eines kontingenten menschlichen
setzungen und ermächtigung sagt damit
wird jede über positive ethik
ausgeschaltet und es wird zu einem
reihen meter ethischen subjektivismus
oder expressionismus
ja so weit ist dieser kleine durchgang
durch durch diese probleme fassung
problem generierung in der historie des
denkens und jetzt zur zweiten frage ist
die problem formulierung adäquat also
mir scheint es aus mehreren gründen
nicht der fall zu sein erstens ist der
begriff des sein verstanden als eine
einzige zusammenhängende einheit der
welt relativ vage und differenzierend
gegenüber den wissenschaftlichen
alltäglichen grundbegriffen dingen etwas
eigenschaft relation und nichts
das zeigt sich auch daran dass es nur
eine schwer sinnvolle konkretisierung
des seins begriffs also und leise nicht
was sind eigentlich konkretisierung des
seins begriffs so sein ist irgendwie
eigenschaft und da sein ist als
philosophischer kunst anzugs und seiner
bedeutung außerordentlich zweifelhaft
und changierend etwa bei hegel und
heidegger noch problematischer ist aber
denke ich der begriff des sollens ist
nicht nur vage und differenzieren
sondern hat negative noch zwei
fundamentale nachteile
er ist erstens nur seit kurzer dauer nur
im deutschen ein existierender
philosophischer kunstbegriff und ist
denke ich ein falscher weise und
gefährlicher weise und kolonisieren dass
sein stehende und damit dinge und
tatsachen sowie die pflicht als geistige
notwendigkeit und damit eigenschaft
unseres denkens werden so fälschlich auf
die gleiche ontologische bei den neu
kanzian dann kann man sagen
erkenntnistheoretische stufe gehoben wie
das sein bzw die wirklichen dinge also
schon rein begrifflich versucht man im
grunde mit dieser nicht wie sie das
sollen auf dieselbe stufe zu heben dann
ist es kein wunder das ist quasi dann
nicht funktioniert mit einer verbindung
oder gar eine ableitung man kann
natürlich sagen dadurch dass man dem
sollen diesen anderen modus dass der
geltung zuspricht wird wieder wird von
dieser hypo sanierung des sollens wieder
etwas weggenommen aber was nun diese
geltung bedeuten soll ist
natürlich extrem zweifelhaft kelsen
behauptete seine existenz modus hätten
eine existenz modus eben diese säulen in
der geltung aber was das dann dafür
heißt es ist schwer verständlich bis
heute ist es denn den vertretern dieser
geltung sub fassung nicht gelungen zu
zeigen was die geltung jenseits einer
kollision regel zwischen normen so
verwenden es die juristen von juristen
ist es eine koalitions regel zwischen
widerstreitenden normen spätere normen
verdrängt die frühere namen höre
genommen verdrängt eben die die
niederrangige norm und so weiter oder
einer zusammenfassung von
verpflichtungen erlauben es umso weiter
sein soll und das zweite zentrale
problem das ich sehe bei diesem soll ins
begriff ist das halt die wertungen durch
den sollens begriff wenn man ihn ernst
nimmt und nicht nur als mischmasch von
säulen und werten ausgeschaltet werden
und zwar fälschlich weil sie fundamental
von presque aktionen unterscheiden und
ein praktischer rechtfertigung eine
wesentliche rolle spielen also das ist
die zweite große problem dieses science
begriff wie kann man nun zu einer
adäquaten formulierung der frage kommen
also ich versuche jetzt mal den pflicht
begriff also obligation ins zentrum zu
stellen und die pflichten können nun
entweder als positiv gesetz dass
bestehendes sein also wenn pflichten
gesetzt sind dann sind sie natürlich
bestehen das ist im grunde das was wir
auch bei herrn nordmann gesehen haben
wenn diese pflichten gesetzt sind dann
sind sie bestehen dass aber auch wenn
sie vor positiv sind dann sind sie auf
eine gewisse art und weise bestehen das
so dass die folgerung wäre alle
pflichten sind als geistige
eigenschaften und dann äußerung auch
eine form des bestehenden aber nicht
alles bestehende ist auch eine pflicht
pflichten sind also nur ein spezifischer
teil des gesamten bestehenden der welt
welches aus nicht psychischen
beziehungsweise nicht sprachlichen und
psychischen sowie sprachlichen besteht
pflichten greifen dann zweitens als
geistige notwendigkeit für unser
verhalten in unserer autonomie ein und
bedürfen deshalb der rechtfertigen
deswegen ist die wesentliche für den
alltag und die anderen wissenschaften
relevante formulierungen des problems
also es ist kein reines kein problem
nach meiner auffassung aber es ist ein
extrem falsch formuliert das problem und
die wesentliche bessere formulierung
lautet eben wie lassen sich pflichten
rechtfertigung beziehungsweise wie
lassen sich wehrt und rechtfertigen
jetzt komme ich zum zweiten
konstruktiven systematischen teil ich
habe ein paar versucht definitionen zu
geben was ist eine pflicht eine
psychische geistige notwendigkeit was
eine verpflichtung eine psychisch
geistige notwendigkeit zum handeln
was ist die äußerung der verpflichtung
eine sprachlich geäußerte
verpflichtungen eine wertung sind
gefühle die mit einem denken im engeren
sinn einen glauben in verbindung stehen
und durch dieses gerechtfertigt werden
die wertungs äußerung ist an die
äußerung eben pflichten sind keine
wertungen sollen ist ungleich von
wertungen wertungen sind eben wie gesagt
gefühle mit meinem denken verbunden sind
und was ist nun der zentrale unterschied
also ich glaube dass pflichten
anders als wertungen immer ein verhalten
bzw einhandeln geistig notwendig machen
während dies wertungen nicht tun das ist
wesentliche punkt den ich quasi
vorschlagen will und über die man
diskutieren kann also pflichten machen
immer ein verhalten beziehungsweise
handeln des verpflichteten notwendig
selbst pflichten gegen sich selbst
während es bei wertungen nicht gilt
das ist völlig klar bei wertungen der
vergangenheit wenn man so zum beispiel
sagt der eiffelturm wurde gut gebaut das
ist eine wertung aber da ist natürlich
keinerlei verpflichtung enthalten es
gibt aber gilt aber denke ich auch für
moralische wertung der gegenwart und
zukunft aus der wertung es wäre gut
weniger co2 zu verbrauchen folgt
keineswegs notwendig oder auch nur ganz
einfach ohne weitere gründe
gerechtfertigt du sollst weniger co2
verbrauchen
ersteres ist nur regelmäßig eine gute
begründung für letzteres und wenn eine
verpflichtung autonom geäußert wird so
kann man auch auf die entsprechende
wertung schließen also denn wenn jemand
einen anderen verpflichtet dann kann man
sagen er bewertet das verhalten zu dem
er den anderen verpflichtet auch positiv
aber selbst das
heldt natürlich nicht in fällen wo zum
beispiel der offizier eben gegenüber dem
unteroffizier die verpflichtung äußert
ich muss ihnen leider den befehl geben
nachwuchs zu gehen und das tut er nur
weil er ihm selbst verpflichtet wurde
okay soweit zu dieser unterscheidung und
nun zum abschluss
wie lassen sich nun solche pflichten ich
beziehe mich jetzt vor allem auf
pflichten rechtfertigen und habe jetzt
da ein paar unterscheidungen wenn sie
auf dem handy hat schauen die erste
ebene zwischen gebote und verbote eine
unterscheidung also dass die handlungs
form der urheberschaft geäußerte
statuierte verpflichtung nicht geäußert
statuierte verpflichtung und schließlich
der anwendungsbereich dieses moralisch
rechtlich konventionelle technik und das
will ich jetzt mal auf dem händler und
wenn sie mitlesen ein bisschen
differenzieren also technische pflicht
wäre ein beispiel die lampe darf nur in
geschlossenen räumen angebracht werden
konventionelle pflicht in der bahn gilt
erst aussteigen lassen das ist wichtig
weil ich nachher ein beispiel damit
konstruieren werde moralische pflicht du
sollst nicht lügen rechtliche pflicht
der beklagte wird verurteilt an den
kläger 100 euro zu bezahlen
und ich habe jetzt einfach mal vier
begründungen aufgelöst um zu zeigen wie
vielfältig die sein können also das ist
eben einfach nicht so dass eine
verpflichtung irgendwie nur begründet
wird durch eine beschreibung oder
sondern es gibt alles möglich also es
gibt allgemeine pflichten zum beispiel
wird die verpflichtung des beklagten an
den kläger 100 euro zuzahlen
gerechtfertigt im urteil dass eben einen
vertrag und 4 33 absatz 2 bgb sagen der
käufer ist verpflichtet dem verkäufer
den kaufpreis zu zahlen es steht in
diesen rechtlichen urteilen dann drin
nach § 4 33 ist das ist die zentrale
begründung die gegeben wird dann kann
ein wollen beziehungsweise ziele können
angenehm so werden es soll kein
kurzschluss in der lampe entstehen der
sie zerstören würde es können wertungen
angegeben werden zum beispiel für das
die verpflichtung nicht zu lügen dass
durch eine lüge bei anderen erzeugte
leid ist schlecht und es könnten
beschreibungen angegeben werden nämlich
neue fahrgäste können in vollen zügen
zu steigen wenn die alten ausgestiegen
sind und jetzt will ich mal diesen
letzten punkt dieses letzte beispielen
mal etwas differenzierter darstellen und
und dazu zeigen versuchen an diesem
beispiel die eigentlich wertungen was
wertungen für eine rolle spielen und das
scheint mir so etwas das problem
jenseits nun der logischen ableitbar
kite oder die dichotomie zwischen nun
beschreibungen und verpflichtungen eben
im alltag oder auch in begründung wie
dem recht zu minimieren muss ja klar
machen selbst wenn ihm recht
verpflichtung ausgesprochen werden dann
steckt da ganz viel inhaltliches drin
und das inhaltliche rechtfertigt außen
also wenn im tatbestand zum beispiel des
betrugs steht wer einen andern täuscht
und dadurch eine vermögens verfügung
herbeiführt dann schließlich steckt
schon im begriff der täuschung eben die
wertung drin dass die täuschung schlecht
ist und die die rechtfertigt das dann
eben also wie geschieht es nun das
denken das wertungen recht verstand
unter anderem eben auch beschreibung
sein und wertungen können dann pflichten
rechtfertigen wenn die wertungen
gravierend sind und die autonomie des
verpflichteten nicht zu stark tangiert
wird also dieser übergang von wertungen
zur verpflichtungen der ist ein
zusätzlicher natürlich und bezieht muss
irgendwie die autonomie des
verpflichteten einbeziehen
und schließlich kann in schwerwiegenden
fällen auch eine äußerung der
verpflichtung gerecht tätig sein wenn
die äußerung die autonomie des
empfängers nicht unverhältnismäßig
einschränkt also der übergang ist nicht
zweistufig sondern denke ich mindestens
drei stufen häufig viel stufig und jetzt
kommt dieses beispiel wenn sie das mal
mit lesen wollen
erstens also dieses beispiel dieser
konventionellen pflicht die wir alle
irgendwie akzeptieren jeder dem zug
gekommen ist hält sich daran dass erst
mal eben die die im zug sind aussteigen
dürfen und die die einsteigen wollen
warten müssen obwohl dann irgendwo
schilder sind das ist sind nirgendwo
schilder bei der bahn also die erfahrung
die allgemeine beschreibung lautet
aussteigen wir werden durch vor ihrem
ausstieg neu einsteigende behindert die
einsteigenden werden durch die
aussteigenden im ausgangsbereich
behindert wenn sie vor dem einstieg zu
steigen also da ist das entscheidende
wort behindert
das ist die beschreibung und dann
zweitens dann kommt eine allgemeine
beschreibende werten der erfahrungssatz
behinderung sind regelmäßig unbequem das
ist natürlich unbequem ist so ein
janusköpfige beschreibender werten der
begriff würde man mit sieben sagen aber
dass diese diesen erfahrungssatz wird
man kaum verneinen können
dann kommt eben die relativ konkrete
beschreibung wertung neue gäste können
vollen zügen erst bequem zusteigen wenn
die dort befindlichen ausgeschieden sind
und dann kommt die allgemeine wertung es
ist gut wenn das aussteigen und
einsteigen bequem abläuft also hier ist
quasi die die verallgemeinerung im
hinblick auf dieses aus und einsteigen
des bequemen und schließlich die
übergeordnete wertung zur ermöglichung
eines guten sozialen miteinanders für
alle sind jenseits von bagatellen also
bei gewisser gewichtigkeit und
verhältnismäßigkeit der autonomie
einschränkung pflichten bzw
verpflichtungen legitim und dann kommt
die allgemeine verpflichtung die
einsteigen müssen warten bis alle die
das wollen ausgestiegen sind ausnahme
rettungseinsätze nothilfe einzelfall 7
die verpflichtung im einzelfall zu pc
1505 und so weiter müssen damit den
hauptbahnhof die einsteigenden warten
und schließlich hat man die
verpflichtung an der stelle aber es aber
man hat noch keine rechtfertigung geben
sie auch zu äußern
und da kann man nur eine übergeordnete
wertung hinzunehmen ist die
verpflichtung als konvention etabliert
allgemein bekannt kommt sie im
einzelfall wegen vieler fahrgäste zu
großen behinderungen ist die autonomie
einschränkungen für die verpflichtende
nicht unverhältnismäßig gravierend so
rechtfertigt das eben die höfliche
äußerung einer verpflichtung und dann
neun diese geäußerte verpflichtung bitte
lassen sie uns erst aussteigen bevor sie
einsteigen
ich denke dass alle diese sätze
beziehungsweise urteile durch ihre
einbettung in der netz weiterer setzte
und urteile gerechtfertigt sind zum
beispiel dieser dieser dieser allgemeine
die übergeordnete wertung das
ermöglichung eines guten sozialen
miteinanders für alle jenseits von
bagatellen
gewisser gewichtigkeit nicht nur
verpflichtung gut sind erscheint mir
eben nicht nur detektiv gerechtfertigt
zu sein sondern auch induktiv das sind
im grunde immer einzel erfahrungen also
wenn das soziale miteinander
gravierender gestört ist dann darf man
eben dem anderen sagen jetzt musst du
halt darauf verzichten sich rein zu
drängen den zug und erst mal die anderen
aussteigen zu lassen oder bei anderen
entsprechenden beeinträchtigt wenn
jemand auf der straße in anderen
gefährdet wie auch immer das heißt mir
scheint nun diese verpflichtung erst
aussteigen lassen überall auf der welt
grundsätzlich gerechtfertigt zu sein und
auch ihre etablierung gerechtfertigter
sein ohne dass es eine übergeordnete
ermächtigung bedarf also dieses ganze
keltische reaktive wollen sollen formale
wollen sollen hierarchie und stufen bau
die scheint mir für weite teile
jedenfalls der moral und ethik aber auch
für das recht nicht nicht gerechtfertigt
zu sein als modell auch im schlecht gibt
es keine strikt detektive ableitung aus
höherrangigen ermächtigung und einer
einzigen grund normen einfach deshalb
weil die ganzen rechtsnormen ja nicht
rein formal sind sondern auch inhaltlich
um die inhaltliche fassung muss auf eine
gewisse art und weise gerechtfertigt
werden und das geschieht nicht nur über
die übergeordnete norm die den inhalt ja
gar nicht legitimieren kann sondern es
geschieht halt dadurch dass es eine
plausible lösung ist dass viele in
einzelfällen diese lösung schon gefunden
haben und die tatsache dass die die
abstraktes rechtsordnung nämlich die
verfassung und geschriebener form
regelmäßig historisch die letzte die
letzte positv rung ist zeigt ja dass im
grunde genommen früher und vielfältiger
und auch rechtfertigen da die grundlage
nun einfach rechtlichen vorschriften war
des strafrechts des zivilrechts das eben
der käufer den kaufpreis bezahlen muss
das ist eine erfahrung die aus vielen
einzelnen verträgen des römischen rechts
des germanischen rechts sich ergeben hat
und die absackte normierung dann im bgb
ist eigentlich nur eben die
gerechtfertigte statuieren dessen was
was sowieso schon als verpflichtend
angenommen wird ich danke herzlich für
aufmerksam freue mich auf die diskussion